I want to pull out this story from the
New York Post because I love this making
women look dumb is a new disturbing
podcast Trend and I'd like for us I'd
like to get my course here here's uh
here's a picture from the whatever
podcast and there's uh Mary Morgan from
uh pop culture crisis they're sitting
with the crew and then you've got uh
Destiny hanging out and uh you know why
I I take issue with this article
because if the whatever podcast has Mary
on the show and she is based and very
smart how are they making women look
dumb when they have women on who also
criticize other women and they criticize
each other like so so who are they
arguing is being made to look dumb are
they arguing the women he brings on are
making Mary look dumb making you Pearl
look dumb I would like to say I was very
offended when I saw this because they
didn't include my podcast in it I don't
know why my picture wasn't there too
I just but but I actually I think you're
right though I think it's stupid like
women make themselves look stupid I
didn't do like I so I've
I've made fun of the whatever podcast
like I did a cartoon about it I
understand why it exists I do understand
it
yes yeah yeah that was me yes yes oh
that was so funny thank you I'm really
glad you enjoyed that that was uh but I
I think that
my my view of it and maybe it's changed
a little bit uh recently actually is you
have this podcast and these young women
who kind of are very young and they just
regurgitate whatever the culture tells
them goes on this show then you have a
guy who's in his 30s who obviously knows
better because he's a guy in his 30s and
he explains to them if they're wrong and
then it gets clipped and it goes viral
and it's like look at this uh dumb girl
one thing I was actually very
I'll say
um impressed by maybe something that
made me feel a little optimistic was
that when the roles were reversed and
Lila Rose was on that show and her is
like a good traditionalist woman she was
arguing with a man who was trying to
justify sleeping around pretty much
everyone in the comments was on her side
and every clip I saw of that video was
people praising her and so it does look
like even though the targets are usually
women what people on this who are
watching these podcasts are upset about
uh is the sexual Revolution and its
consequences and they don't like when
people kind of engage in these
rationalizations for this type of
behavior yeah yeah you know you know
what it is funny thing uh I will point
out though a trend on Instagram is for
women to make fake podcast Clips have
you noticed this no no on Instagram
female influencers will buy these
microphones and then they'll say
something
that's genius yeah yeah it'll be a clip
it'll just be them talking to one and
they'll say something like I think that
men should be good providers and too
many women you know insert opinion and
that's the end of the clip it's gonna
million views why do I even do my whole
hour-long podcast why do we do this Tim
let's just make Clips let's make fake
shorts for YouTube oh that's crazy I
think that the older women are more
delusional that's my how so well it's
like I just think they're Dumber on my
show hold on when you say older women do
you mean older women are like older
women who are single because that's also
two separate categories right
um
I mean I'd say the majority of people
that go on the shows are single okay so
but like I thought you're gonna say
you're dumb but I just wanna I just want
to point this out but I I would just
sorry no no finish your boyfriend I
would just say that I think that the
older women are more delusional on my
show and I think that's a lot of times
like why men date younger because
they're like thinking they'll be like
better when they're older but they're
they're just as delusional so look at
this New York Post says while only fans
model Nicolette Nicole admitted that her
appearance on the podcast was to bolster
her own following she told Vice the
clips were definitely chosen to create
controversy and make her look dominant
shamer no no the only thing I want to
point out is calling somebody that only
fans a model
hahaha
no but you don't be mad okay because
with the girls will do is they'll go on
the show and then after they'll play
victim like oh boo hoo poor me they've
done this on my show so many times where
like they'll come on and then they'll
they'll they'll sometimes say out
straight out missandrist
misandristic statements and then go back
later and say oh I'm a victim blah blah
blah when it's like if you say dumb
like there's so many women that go on
these shows and don't go viral and don't
say stupid and actually go viral
for the right reasons but if you go
viral for saying something stupid that's
that's your own fault well that's the
thing they say uh so the the article
it's being cited by the New York Post is
vice and their subhead is the whatever
podcast is baked you can stop falling
for it no it isn't they had Lila Rose
and Mary Morgan on that show where are
the clips making fun of them they're not
in fact the clips are praising them the
clip of Lila went viral because she was
like telling a guy off and then people
were like wow she's very smart even she
like she wasn't telling him off he was
trying to tell her often she was just
very calmly like stating her position
it's funny because I saw one of these
red pill channels posted to try to shame
her they're like oh this woman tries to
tell this Alpha what's what but all of
the comments on their Channel were like
no she's right like this guy's
completely wrong what Vice is actually
doing is saying stop making us look dumb
because we're dumb well they're no no
they're saying stop making the sexual
Revolution look bad because if this was
a bunch of left-wing men talking down to
women who were Trad wives and saying
you're an idiot who's missing out on
what you should be doing in life they
would say this podcast is great you
think do you think that it's women
should be like I think what happens a
lot of people get offended is the
thought that a woman is supposed to be
raising kids you're you are your job in
life is to be a wife and a mother and
like not everybody wants that I mean
maybe you might maybe people will argue
that every woman deep down does want
that the majority of women do want that
I would say I I think they surveyed
childless women or like it was like 80
or something 85 percent said they wanted
kids I can't remember the actual study I
think the issue is like they can't find
the right guy to have kids with or the
guy that they want
and like that and usually when I like I
talk to girls on the show they'll say
like I'm happy single or I'm happy not
having kids and I'll like if I ask
further questions and say like what
about if you found like the guy that
meets all your criteria and the majority
of the time they'll say yes yeah I I
remember I just want to mention this I
was at a bar with my my uncle my cousin
were visiting and so we were all at the
bar and her and I were the same age so
we must have been like 22 23 at the time
we're talking to this bartender who's
probably in her 40s and my cousin says
you know I'm like never gonna have kids
and the bartender's like how old are you
she's like I'm 22 and the bartender goes
shut up stop he's like shut up you're
22. you have no idea what you want no 22
year olds should and they I agree that
they should but in this culture they
don't and if someone is telling you like
I know I don't want to have kids here's
the thing if they're not saying I will
sacrifice having a family and sacrifice
having children because there is a
broader Noble goal which I wish to
achieve then okay I think that's a
person who probably does know what they
want and can take you can take seriously
but if they're saying I know in my early
20s I don't want to have kids and it's
for selfish reasons okay this is just
someone who's immature that's not like a
well thought out Life Plan that's I want
to do things that make me feel good
instead of thinking about what I can
contribute I've learned pretty early on
that to not use terms say I'll never do
something or I'll always do something
it's just it always fails no it's just
that video remember that video of the of
the kids in like the 50s they're being
asked about war whatever and they sound
like adults I know because it used to be
right it used to be that kids were
surrounded by adults and learned very
quickly how to socially interact what
was and what wasn't now kids do nothing
for five years we put them in front of
iPads or computer screens and they watch
Elsa another nonsense then they go to
kindergarten where they dance around
with pride Flags then they get
institutionalized and learn garbage
nonsense for like they don't learn real
world things then finally by the time
they're 22 they get out of college
having been institutionalized their
whole lives and they don't know how to
operate in the real world yeah it's
because it's not a biological problem I
mean it might be an endocrine system
problem but I'm the culture I look
online and I'm like okay there are so
many hot girls there's so many hot girls
online I'll watch whatever I watch all
these and I'm like these are beautiful
young women Prime candidates for
motherhood like and where why are they
not having kids what is going on you
know what the number one like indicator
I forgot what the status but it's
basically like the birth rate goes down
when women go to college so like women
start having like less children when
they started going to college and it's
and and they also when mate selection
was more in the woman's hands basically
what happened when it became more in the
woman's hands yeah because because like
in the 20s that was when women started
to get their own apartment so like
before they would go straight from the
dad to the husband
and like then women like started to go
and get like the Roaring 20s right they
started getting their own apartment and
like they then had more control of their
mate selection and like when women have
more control of their mate selection
they go for a smaller and smaller
percentage of guys where it's like you
know I mean why would they keep the bad
boy away when they say like get that guy
away from my daughter because they like
the dad knew he's not gonna stick around
but women it's like we're just so stupid
when it comes to mate selection just
because you work not you personally but
work with emotions instead of yeah
instead of logic
yeah and and it's also like I don't
think we have a good grasp of like our
league like I think women often sleep
out of their league well that that
that's that's the factually true though
yeah like all of the uh scientific
research and and uh dating data yeah
show that women always go for the most
attractive men but they tend to be able
to because men have a wider range of
willingness about like women have a very
tight range of their willingness to
sleep and men have a very wide range
right so what happens is it's something
like what like the bottom six percent of
guys are just like left out of it and
then it's mostly the top 20 of guys who
are sleeping with all of the women yeah
well and and the other thing they
they'll always say oh well dating apps
aren't real life but that's the number
one way people are meeting under 30.
that's true dude those things are
depression have you ever used those
things the dating apps no not really
yeah I started to do it for market
research because I was building mines in
the social app we're like let's maybe do
a Tinder thing and then I got addicted
to it I met a girl on it and it was like
just I'm like look why I'm judging these
people by the way they look it's the
most superficial crap and I felt sick
depressed afterwards well I mean it's
honest I think most guys it starts with
looks you know but it's like the sound
of their voice and the way they smell is
a big dude it's just to go on and swipe
right on every single one because
there's like the the I was I was reading
uh
data on how men and women use these apps
differently women go on dating apps and
then swipe right on guys they find
attractive and then get messages from
every single guy and then guys go on
there and swipe on every single girl
hoping one of them matches with them
right well think about it like women
swipe right five percent of the time
guys it's like there's a video where
guys
swiping everything it's like between 40
and 60 depends on the time of day if
it's after one a.m it's probably gonna
be like 70 or 80 because I'm in a
desperate mode I'm not anymore but at
the time I was that was uh yeah you know
but it's interesting because women like
pick non-monogamy in our 20s and then
pick monogamy in our 30s when you think
about it but that but that's obvious you
know why
like it's getting harder for the woman
as she gets older so now she's like I
need a guy who's not going to go
anywhere yeah but that but again like so
when you have a culture like ours where
the the sexual revolution has just
completely destroyed the relationship
between both sexes that seems to be what
tends to happen but like in most
traditional cultures that's not the case
right like people settle down early they
get married women are known for straying
less often than than men do and so this
is part of what I was emphasizing
earlier this is why and I believe Fulton
Sheen even said this like a society's
value can be measured by the value of
its women because the men are always
going to want to sleep around the
question is uh are women going to be the
gatekeeper and say well like no we're
we're not having sex unless we're
married unless you can provide a stable
uh home and family for myself and for
our children and you're actually going
to stick around
I guess there's a diminishing return to
raising Psychopaths like if you'd have a
lot of kids that were all horrible
humans that would be worse than having
very few kids that were phenomenal
humans but then there comes a point
where it's like population risk you
might lose the human population if you
don't have enough kids so it's better to
just churn them out but like I think
that in order like is it better or worse
in other societies where they didn't
have a sexual Revolution the thing is we
have well no Society has survived a
sexuality I think it's coming everywhere
I think like with social media like I
and I get messages from guys all over
the world saying okay like feminism is
coming and you have places that were
typically like more traditional like
India is a one percent divorce rate and
I get messages all the time like saying
that under 30 and I don't know the exact
stat but under 30 like the divorce rate
is rising because Western ideas are
going everywhere and in my opinion most
places I think like I think it's going I
don't want it to get bad like I don't
want it to get worse but if I had to
predict it I think like you will see
women getting more modern well you've
seen the psychological operations the
military's been doing they get like a 20
year old like e-girl and then they have
her make an account where she's talking
about how great it is to be in the army
or the Navy or whatever to get Sims to
join yeah oh my goodness of operations
with what Pearl's saying about how in
countries that were more traditional you
see an increase in these abnormal
lifestyle choices this is the one form
of colonization and imperialism that the
left is very very comfortable with
if we went into these countries and we
destroyed their temples or took their
gold the left would be very upset and
rightfully so but instead what we're
doing is exporting ideas that literally
destroy these people's families and it's
praised it's celebrated but I wonder if
you were able to pull because now we're
in the age of of revealment you know the
Revelation we're in we're in the the
apocalypse essentially we're seeing the
thoughts of people now that we didn't
used to see so yeah we're seeing the
misery of the unmarried but if we had
seen into the minds of people in 1938
would they be Miser just as miserable or
more because they were getting beat by
their husbands like Sean Connery check
this analysis that men were all just
beating their wives yeah like oh that's
a way of a propaganda that they did in
like the 40s I can't remember when they
did it there's this girl who like breaks
it down really well her name's Rachel
Wilson she wrote the book of cult
feminism but the propaganda like it was
mainly propaganda this idea that like
men were beating their wives left and
right like they it's a wave of
propaganda that was like between the 40s
and the 60s
yeah well you obviously have always had
men who were bad people there have been
horrible human beings throughout all of
history thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time